in El Paso Texas and eco fascists
slaughtered 20 people in a shopping mall
shooting the next day in Dayton Ohio a
socialist Satanist leftist slaughtered
nine people including his own sister at
a bar leftist partisans rushed to blame
Trump and conservatives conservatives
eager to fight the unfair attacks want
to disavow any connection whatsoever to
the ideology of the El Paso shooter we
will examine the reality there are very
terrible people on both sides how could
these attacks have been prevented how
can they be prevented in the future
president Trump weighs in and we weigh
in on his weighing in then the
Democratic socialists of America tried
to topple capitalism at their National
Convention but failed to even finish the
announcements without in fighting over
pronouns and phony grievances finally
Quentin Tarantino delivers in Once Upon
a Time in Hollywood all that and more
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles Oh
[Music]
so much to get to today obviously
horrific shootings over the weekend in
Texas and in Ohio and the way it's
played out has been so predictable you
had these two shootings apparently both
motivated by ideology one very clearly
by ideology and that's a mostly
right-wing ideology though not a totally
right-wing ideology then the second
shooting appears to have been motivated
by an almost exclusively left-wing
ideology and in response the left not
the right
the left blamed its political opponents
on the right this was not a both sides
or throwing blame the left totally
unfairly blamed the right for this and
then the right in reacting to it wanted
to disavow any connection obviously to
the Texas shooting in particular and so
they said the guy's ideology has nothing
to do with conservatism has nothing to
do with the right the reality is a
little more complicated than that
and the hard truth is there are terrible
people on both sides of the aisle so
we'll get into a little bit of exactly
what motivated each shooting because the
the broad narrative is what the left
wants to promote so the left just wants
its own narrative no details no
specificity so that it can ram through
its own policy goals details are the
enemy of the left and we'll get into the
details and we'll get into Trump's
response which I thought generally was
very good though there were a couple
couple issues with it we'll get to that
in a second but first we've got to thank
our friends over at zip recruiters zip
recruiter sends your job to over 100 of
the web's leading job boards go to zip
recruiter comm slash Knowles zip
recruiter does not stop right there with
their powerful matching technology zip
recruiter scans thousands of resumes to
find people with the right experience
and invites them to apply it to your job
I repeat go to zip recruiter comm slash
Knowles you got to do it because you
don't want to waste time this is what
zip recruiter does so in the old days
you'd throw spaghetti at the wall and
you'd say okay I really really hope
something comes up and I really hope I
can fill this job and I really and we'll
just see what happens I hope someone
emails me that's not what happens as
applications come in to zip recruiter
zip recruiter will analyze each one and
spot
like the top candidates so that you
never miss a great match it's actively
out there doing the work for you that's
what super cruder sets itself apart with
so it's so effective that four out of
five of the employers who post on zip
recruiter get a quality candidate
through the website in just one day
right now my listeners can try zip
recruiter for free at this exclusive web
address zip recruiter comm slash Knowles
Cana wles that is zip recruiter comm
slash Knowles zip recruiter comm slash
nolza perk Rooter the smartest way to
hire let's get into the details here
what happened in El Paso this was the
first shooting a 21 year old shooter
opened fire at the Cielo Vista Mall at
least 20 people were killed hopefully no
more people are killed a lot of people
were injured though 27 injured the
shooter posted a manifesto online and it
appears to be authentic and it
circulated around the internet now
websites are trying to take it down as
some people are saying don't read the
manifesto I don't believe that that's
not my reaction to it I always read the
manifesto I always want to know as much
information as I can as to why these
people committed these crimes you can't
always believe the shooters often
they're a little crazy often they're
liars but to just say that it's
senseless violence is to put your head
in the sand because when these shooters
tell you that they have a reason for
what they're doing we ought to at least
take that seriously when the 9/11
hijackers say we have a reason that
we're doing what we're doing it's
because we believe our religion is
telling us to topple these two towers
you you at least have to take that
seriously you can't just put your
fingers in your ears and say lalala I
don't believe it it's senseless so what
does the shooter say motivated him in El
Paso the manifesto is short spent four
pages and the ideologies that he
embraces is something called eco fascism
now the left is saying this is a
completely right-wing ideology they're
the left is blaming Trump for this
shooter the shooter himself says don't
blame Trump I believe these things long
before Donald Trump ever entered the
political scene
the reality of this ideology is that
it's a little bit right-wing and it's a
little bit left-wing
so basically neither side right now is
correct the left is saying it's all
right wing a lot of conservatives are
saying this guy has nothing to do with
the righties only a leftist neither is
really telling the truth or neither at
least is really getting it right they
might think they're telling the truth
but they're not eco fascism does not
neatly fit on the left or on the right
so in some ways it's very associated
with the right it's anti-illegal
immigration it's anti immigration
broadly it has this very racist category
which again doesn't cut right or left
but it has this very racial bigoted
category which is he's anti race mixing
he's not exactly a white supremacist but
he's certainly a white nationalist or a
white segregationist he wants there to
be different areas of the country for
different races so at the at the base of
his politics is racial essentialism this
would be categor categorized to under
the label alt right if you want to know
more about what the alt right actually
is not just what Hillary Clinton
pretends that it is but if you want to
know what the term at least once used to
mean you can check out my Prague review
video on this topic alt stands for
alternative it's an alternative version
of the right to what we would consider a
more traditional conservatism I mean
they're calling it right-wing he
identifies as right-wing in in many of
his policy prescriptions or policy
preferences he probably would be
considered right-wing so in that way the
right does have an association with him
but the Eco part is the this intense
environmentalism which would be these
days exclusively found on the left and
it's a fascism rooted in the environment
so he totally buys into the global
warming alarmism he says corporations
are destroying our environment
politicians of both parties are
destroying our environment we need to
save our environment now it's an intense
environmentalism which which is strongly
on the Left though this in kind of
environmentalism has had a tie to
fascism for a long time there's the what
has now become a cliche which is the
observation that
Hitler was a vegetarian he he was a
fascist he killed all of these people he
was a horrible mass murderer and yet he
wouldn't kill an animal because he was a
vegetarian there is a strain of fascism
that embraces this because fascism
especially as the Nazis talked about it
was blood and soil so the idea that it's
not just about the race but it's about
the geography the soil we need to
protect our natural environment and it
can be taken to this insane extreme
which is basically sacrificing even our
own humanity to preserve the collective
natural environment that's the ideology
that's about is this I mean we could go
into this for two hours but I think
that's the broad view of the ideology
it's got a lot of components of the
right this love of tradition want to
preserve the nation it's got a lot of
aspects of the left this hyper
environmentalism even at the expense of
human flourishing that beyond the
ideology what can we look to well like
so many mass shooters this guy comes
from a broken home before I even knew it
I read the manifesto and I said you know
before I exclusively ascribe this to
ideologies let me just Google shooters
named divorce guess what
the parents of this guy divorced when he
was 13 the father has written
extensively about his 40 years of drug
addiction so obviously the the father
was just a total degenerate for much of
this kid's life and this is often
happens but beneath the kind of
political level there is a cultural
level something just wasn't right with
this kid something that kid now adult
but when he was a kid certainly when
they divorced something was broken in
the home we see this beyond just mass
shootings we see this in the regular
homicides that happen all the time we
see this in gang violence often one
explanation of gang violence as these
kids come from broken homes they have no
fathers at home yep looks like that may
have been at play here now in this case
the suspect was apprehended alive so he
wasn't killed even though he wished to
be killed in his manifesto
so he'll likely face the death penalty
as he should
and we'll get into what President Trump
has to say about that in just a second
but moving over to the next day's mass
shooting in Dayton Ohio
same thing young guy 24 year old young
man opened fire in an Ohio bar on Sunday
at least nine people dead including his
sister in 27 people injured now on the
surface these events look kind of
similar young white men so the media
irresponsible media irresponsible
Democratic candidates for president
irresponsible leftist pundits have been
saying they're both obvious white
supremacy there's no evidence that the
second shooter was a white supremacist
or a fascist or in any way associated
with the right actually when you look
into social media pages it looks as
though he was a lad radical leftist he
described himself as a Satanist he
described himself as a socialist he
described himself as a leftist this is
what he said he wrote quote I want
socialism and I'll not wait for the
idiots to finally come around to
understanding when President Trump won
in 2016 he said this is bad he wrote
quote vote blue for God's sake
he wrote F John McCain bizarrely this
guy actually wrote in favor of gun
control and leftist gun policies after
the Parkland shooting happened he
tweeted out quote this is America guns
on every corner guns in every house no
freedom but that to kill he apparently
tweeted to rob portman the Republican
senator quote hey Rob how much did they
pay you to look the other way
seventeen kids are dead if not now when
obviously something snapped in this
guy's ideology or in his mental
faculties or likely both who does he
endorse Elizabeth Warren he says Warren
I'd happily vote for he said kill every
fascist there you see a lot more
violence creeping cut the fences down
meaning the border wall and the border
detention centers slice ice tires
immigration Customs Enforcement throw
bolt cutters over the fences and he
listed his pronouns as he and him so
this guy was a radical leftist you don't
see that in the mainstream news coverage
but there's not a not a hint of anything
right-wing war of white supremacy or any
of that
he's obviously radical
leftist now despicably cynical leftist
politicians and pundits and commentators
are blaming President Trump and quote
white supremacy for these shootings in
reality one of these shootings was
perpetrated by probably a trump
supporter anti-immigration advocate and
white supremacists and all those other
things but at least on the policy level
we know he was opposed to immigration so
I guess very likely he would prefer
President Trump to some open borders
politician right that's one of the
shooters and then the other shooting was
perpetrated by a radical leftist who
explicitly endorsed Elizabeth Warren now
in reality neither of these were caused
by Trump or Warren or Bernie Sanders or
any of these other politicians these
people are responsible for their own
actions but that didn't stop the left
and just the left exclusively the left
from using these barely cold dead bodies
to push their own hack cynical political
agendas here's what Elizabeth Warren
tweeted out quote we need to call that
white nationalism for what it is
domestic terrorism it is a threat to the
United States and we've seen its
devastating toll this weekend and we
need to call out the President himself
for advancing racism and white supremacy
okay if you believe that if you believe
that premise which I don't I don't
believe the premise that when mass
shooters quote politicians the
politicians are responsible for the
shooting but if you believe that premise
then you need to apologize for the
shooting in Ohio don't you you need to
bear responsibility for the shooting on
Ohio Elizabeth Warren because the
shooter in Ohio explicitly endorsed you
now she won't do that because she
doesn't care doesn't care about the
victims doesn't care about the policy
doesn't care about any of it
other than promoting herself in the 2020
Democratic presidential primaries in a
way that is absolutely disgusting
even by the measure of presidential
politics I understand in presidential
political campaigns people are going to
just use
exploit events for disgusting purposes
this is especially disgusting and
Elizabeth Warren should be ashamed of
herself if she had the capacity for
shame she would feel shame but she
doesn't she's the whitest woman in
America who pretended to be an Indian
Native American for her entire career in
a way that would take jobs away from
Native Americans in a way to look with
her white face look people dead in the
eye and say I am a Cherokee Indian
give me preferential treatment at
Harvard and in the Texas bar I mean that
sort of shameless person would
absolutely have no problem using barely
cold dead bodies for her own political
purposes but she's not the only one I
don't mean only to single out Elizabeth
Warren here AOC and Bernie Sanders
get in on the disgusting exploitation
before President Trump shows up is the
only adult in the room we'll get to that
in a second but first I got to thank our
friends over at rocket mortgage by
Quicken Loans finding the right house is
not easy and I would know that because I
live in LA and looking to find a house
here you finally find one nice house you
think okay this nice little two-bedroom
this will be perfect then you look up
the price it's like 10 million dollars
or something like that the whole process
is very difficult anyway because once
you find that as and you got to get a
mortgage it's probably the biggest
financial decision you're ever gonna
make it just gets so complicated unless
you have rocket mortgage because rocket
mortgage makes it easy their team of
mortgage experts is obsessed with
finding a better way which means that
their number one goal is to make the
home buying process smoother for you
with industry-leading
online lending technology developed in
the heart of Detroit rocket mortgage is
changing the game they make the home
buying process work for you in fact
rocket mortgages there with
award-winning client service and support
every step of the way
their team cares about getting you home
that's why we're Quicken Loans is ranked
highest in customer satisfaction for
primary mortgage origination nine years
in a row and highest in mortgage
servicing five years in a row don't you
know don't go into making the biggest
financial decision that likely you're
ever going to make in one of the most
complicated processes in one of the
easiest ways to go wrong don't do it
without the best time and again you can
see rocket mortgage they are
the best let them work for you rocket
mortgage is more than just a lender get
started at rocket mortgage calm slash
Knowles candor wles
Equal Housing lender licensed in all 50
states n MLS consumer access number 30
30
rocket mortgage by Quicken Loans push
button get mortgage so it's not just the
shameless Elizabeth Warren exploiting
dead bodies for her own personal gain
alexandria casio cortez did it too she
tweeted out in response to the
suggestion that video games and other
cultural aspects that celebrate violence
might have played some role in this
shooting she tweets that video games
aren't causing mass shootings white
supremacy is sadly the GOP refuses to
acknowledge that because their strategy
relies on rallying a white supremacist
base that's why the president has
stadiums of people chanting sent her
back and targets congress members of
color okay if you believe this premise
if you believe this premise that anyone
who holds an idea that is also held well
actually no i'm sorry what is the idea
the idea of white supremacy right so i'm
sorry i got i must have gotten a little
confused there for a second because
she's ascribing white supremacy to
president trump president Trump has
repeatedly condemned white supremacy
right he's repeatedly condemned racism
how many times a year does this guy
condemn racism which conservative member
of Congress of the Senate the president
which governor which of them says I'm a
white supremacist I love white supremacy
none of them zero boo nada none of them
do but let's take her premise at its
word and let's just let's just replace
white supremacy with socialism
yes socialism okay because we know that
the shooter in Ohio was a leftist
socialist Satanist okay let's see video
games aren't causing mass shootings
socialism is I remember actually the guy
who shot up the Congressional baseball
game was a Bernie bro socialist sadly
the GOP Democrats refused to acknowledge
that because their strategy relies on
rallying a socialist base that's why the
congresswoman from Queen
hosts rooms of people chanting I don't
know
socialism bring us socialism tax the
rich soak the rich and targets Congress
members of baseball games see how easy
that is see in the case of a OCS tweet
it didn't make any sense because no
conservative is embracing white
supremacy but the shooter in Ohio was an
avowed socialist she is embracing
socialism she's promoting socialism Tom
Perez says she's the head the future of
the Democratic Party so are we gonna
blame aoc are we gonna blame bernie
sanders i don't i don't want to do that
but by aoc s logic looks like aoc needs
to take responsibility for the shooting
in ohio and then of course there's
bernie sanders mr. president stop your
racist hateful and anti-immigrant
rhetoric your language creates a climate
which emboldened violent extremists a
Bernie bro shot up the Congressional
baseball game do you senator sanders
bear responsibility for the attack on
the Congressional baseball game that
almost murdered Steve Scalise by your
logic here which I don't believe you
Bernie Sanders are responsible for
almost murdering Steve Scalise now they
would never accept responsibility
because they don't care they're just
saying words and words to exploit dead
bodies for their political game
fortunately President Trump came as the
adult in the room and this almost sounds
funny because we say president Trump II
sometimes behaves in a childish manner
he hurls insults at his opponents he can
seem petulant President Trump is far and
away the adult in the room in this
situation so he shows up and he gives it
remarks this morning they just came out
a couple hours ago quite good he started
out by condemning bigotry explicitly as
it was described in the el paso shooters
manifesto here he is in one voice our
nation must condemn racism bigotry and
white supremacy these sinister
ideologies must be defeated hate has no
place in America hatred warps the mind
ravages the heart and devours the soul
great yeah this was the right thing to
say he said it per I don't know how he
could have said it more clearly now the
other aspect of why this comment was so
great is he didn't go as far as he could
have to hammer the left right he could
have easily said racism and white
supremacy and bigotry racial bigotry is
absolutely awful and that's what we saw
in El Paso also Satanism leftism and
socialism are awful that's what we saw
in Ohio but he didn't say that and this
was smart it shows that he learns it
shows that he gets a little savvy err
because that would have just been a
repeat of their fine people on both
sides now even though we know that in
Charlottesville when he said they were
fine people on both sides that he was
explicitly condemning neo-nazism white
supremacism white nationalism racism
bigotry what-have-you
even though we know that it was totally
twisted and politically it still is
hurting him if he had said we condemn
racism and bigotry we condemn Satanism
and leftism he I guess he would have
been right but he's smart also because
there was no leftist manifesto in Ohio
not that we know of right so we're
pretty certain we know who this guy is I
mean he he had a long social-media
record so we we think we have an idea
but still it's not totally clear so we
just I mean President Trump is playing a
little more cautious here he was very
smart only to focus on the Eco fascist I
mean he's just he's just gotten savvy er
about all of this then he turns his
attention on finding solutions so the
first solution he offers is probably
what most of us were not expecting it's
a little bit vague it's he's just
talking about the Internet issues on the
Internet and the way that information
moves around the Internet in the way
that people get radicalized on the
Internet first we must do a better job
of identifying and acting on early
warning signs I am directing the
Department of Justice to work in
partisan partnership with local state
and federal agencies
as well as social media companies to
develop tools that can detect mass
shooters before they strike as an
example the monster in the Parkland High
School in Florida had many red flags
against him and yet nobody took decisive
action nobody did anything why not so
the first one is the internet right
there were a lot of these warning signs
this is very smart and it's tied to
mental health and this is the real trick
here so and he ties it to Parkland which
is really smart there's going to be a
great new book coming out very soon on
how that parkland shooting in Florida
came to happen there were so many
warning signs along the way and the
schools did nothing so many warning
signs on social media on the internet in
chat logs schools did nothing this is a
little bit of a dangerous point to bring
up because you never want to censor the
internet you know if you start censoring
the internet that can go real wrong real
quickly you could all of us I mean
frankly the left is already censoring
the internet by kicking off
conservatives you don't want to get into
that kind of world but you do want to be
able to use warning signs on the
Internet you know this guy in in Dayton
Ohio he apparently had a kill list and a
rape list they would write on the wall
of the school people had been chatting
about this people knew about this why
didn't someone step in why didn't
someone heed the warning signs this is
tied to mental health with Trump Trump
gets to in a second then Trump gets to
his second suggestion which i think is a
little bit weaker I think this is the
weakest of all of his arguments and it
has to do broadly with a culture of
violence and specifically video games
second we must stop the glorification of
violence in our society this includes
the gruesome and grisly video games that
are now commonplace it is too easy today
for troubled youth to surround
themselves with a culture that
celebrates violence
we must stop or substantially reduce
this and it has to begin immediately I
don't know if this is true I don't know
if this is false you know when I was a
when I was a kid I didn't play video
games a lot but there was was one vile
video game Grand Theft Auto that I
played for I don't know six months or
something and was playing it and then
when I when I went to learn how to drive
I did have this impulse to drive like a
maniac I didn't do it fortunately well I
mean I drove like a maniac like all
teenagers do but I didn't you know drive
like I was in a video game but I did
have this impulse I distinctly remember
it thinking like oh I should swerve into
that land and swerve over here and and
obviously that had just been kind of
bred into my mind because I played this
video game a lot for a few months maybe
video games have something to do with it
our culture has always been violent our
culture or pop culture has always been
violent I don't think it's the violence
itself I think it's the fact that in the
old days the violence had a an order to
it it had a purpose it had a moral
context and today violence is pretty
much nihilistic random arbitrary absurd
senseless I think those are two
different things
don't forget our culture that the three
biggest poems that found our entire
culture are all war poems the Iliad the
Odyssey and the Aeneid they're all about
one specific war which is one of the
bloodiest war is ever written about
which is the Trojan War the Aeneid
begins arms and the man I sing I mean
the first lines I'm gonna sing about war
and all this gory crazy violence but
that was war with a purpose that was war
with a moral universe a war that had
value where that had honor and valor and
purpose and even a sense of good and
evil the lone ranger one of the biggest
shows from the 1950s it's about a good
guy getting the outlaws getting the bad
guys but in modern depictions of
violence it's just senseless it's just
crazy there might be something there too
that cultural problem I think Trump
probably has it then he gets to the key
the biggest issue of all which is mental
health we will examine that in a second
but first you got to go to Facebook
you've got to get off of Facebook in
YouTube go to daily wire calm 10 bucks a
month $100 for an annual membership you
get me you get the Indra Clavin sure you
get the Ben Shapiro show you get the mat
wall show you test questions in the
mailbag coming up on Thursday you have
to ask questions backstage you get
another Kingdom you get to check out a
full episode of the
Shapiro Sundays special featuring me
this is Ben's favorite episode of the
Sunday special ever I want to thank
everyone who's already listened who shot
that episode up to number six I think in
the overall iTunes and pod Apple podcast
charts please go over there and check it
out give it a download because if you do
that and it reaches say number one Ben
will have to have me on the Sunday
special again which will break his heart
and will cause me to laugh uproariously
so please go do that check it out of
daily we're calm we'll be right back
with a lot more
President Trump then gets to the heart
of the matter on the solution this is
really correct he's talking about mental
health third we must reform our mental
health laws to better identify mentally
disturbed individuals who may commit
acts of violence and make sure those
people not only get treatment but when
necessary involuntary confinement mental
illness and hatred pulls the trigger not
the gun there it is
that's the key involuntary confinement
involuntary commitment of the mentally
ill today this is taboo on both sides
the left doesn't want to do it because
the left is completely insane and the
left doesn't really even believe in the
concept of mental illness they sort of
celebrate mental illness they say let's
all talk about our mental illness we're
all mentally ill and the right doesn't
want to talk about it because we don't
want to give the government that much
power to involuntarily commit people but
this is the key today it is virtually
impossible to do it but in the 1950s we
had a we had a peak high of mentally ill
confined people then states began to
empty the asylums in the 1960s actually
Ronald Reagan of all people helped that
process along he didn't begin the
process but he did help it along when he
was governor of California and we need
to be able to do it I mean a huge
proportion of these people have clear
signs of mental illness if not all of
them and we need to be able to take them
off of the street I mean President Trump
makes this great point which is that men
guns don't kill people mentally ill
people kill people that's the it's the
mental illness it's the psychological
process that leads to the decision to
pull that trigger the trigger doesn't
just pull itself and it is it is not
just is not fair it is not sustainable
to allow dangers to society to be on the
street there's no we do it for because
of a false sense of freedom because we
we think freedom just means anything
goes it doesn't people who are mentally
ill are not capable of freedom
actually people who are totally
uneducated totally uncultured totally
disengaged from their civilization also
are not capable of their freedom the
founding fathers and the the people who
have constructed our republic had a very
elevated view of freedom you had to earn
your freedom you had to become fit to
govern yourself you had to be moral you
had to be virtuous you had to be
religious you had to be educated you
have to be sane in order to have some
freedom and if not then that it's not
that that Liberty will be taken from you
it's that you you are not capable of
that Liberty in the first place
so that would be a good place to start
is building some more mental asylums and
throwing people who are a danger to
society into them getting them drugs I
mean one of the reasons why they emptied
out in the 1960s and 70s is because we
had all these good psychological drugs
now and we could cure people so if
someone had some mental illness they
take a drug it seemed like they were
cured so we would let them out of the
asylum and then what happens instantly
they stop taking the drugs they wind up
on the street or they wind up to be a
threat to others that's one way to do it
and then President Trump hits with great
moral clarity on what we should do about
the killers now today I'm also directing
the Department of Justice to propose
legislation ensuring that those who
commit hate crimes and mass murders face
the death penalty and that this capital
punishment be delivered quickly
decisively and without years of needless
delay yep Trump has a lot of moral
clarity on this issue so one of the guys
who shot up the bar in Ohio he was
killed but the guy who shot up the El
Paso Texas Mall was not killed he was
apprehended and he should face the death
penalty and he should face the death
penalty swiftly you got to remember I
know it's unpopular these days there's
three purposes of capital punishment
retribution deterrence and
rehabilitation
now rehabilitation doesn't seem like it
factors in a whole lot on in terms of
capital punishment it actually does have
a rolling capital punishment in the
sense that it can reform one's mind as
he prepares to meet his maker
face the gallows but broadly speaking on
criminal justice those are the three
purposes retribution deterrence and
rehabilitation and retribution is the
key an injustice has been committed and
for that injustice because the civil
authority exact justice for which we
have a civil of criminal justice system
the criminal has to be punished just for
committing the crime and then there's
the deterrence factor so if capital
punishment isn't a great deterrent now
when we have 30 or 40 year waiting
periods to kill people and we need to
enact the exact justice rather swiftly
we need to do it quickly that will
increase the deterrent effect a few
facts to keep in mind here as we hear
the endless debate that is just
beginning you're gonna hear gun control
brought up a lot there is no gun control
law that would have prevented either of
these shootings not one anyone who tells
you otherwise is lying to you and
they're exploiting your emotions to
affect their political purposes and
they're exploiting dead bodies to affect
their political goals there is a reform
that could have stopped maybe the Ohio
shooting the Ohio shooter had that hit
list he had that rape list I mean he was
clearly a demented person he could have
been committed to a mental institution
he could have been denied his civil
liberties he could have been denied his
second Amendment rights he could have
been an I to other civil liberties too
but that's a mental health issue that's
not a gun control issue you can't just
take away people's civil rights Second
Amendment rights willy-nilly just
because you don't like them or you don't
like the cut of their jib you can take
away their civil rights if they are not
deemed fit for liberty if they're not
deemed fit to behave as individuals in a
free society
if you commit them to him to an insane
asylum that's what they could have done
no that's not a gun control law that is
a mental health reform also on gun
control as they tell you all gun control
laws would have fixed it don't forget
President Trump is sympathetic to gun
control he has passed certain gun
control measures he actually bragged in
his remarks about how after the last big
mass shooting in Las Vegas
he banned bump stocks here's his ears
his boast at
direction the Department of Justice band
bump stocks last year we prosecuted a
record number of firearms offenses but
there is so much more that we have to do
now you see that he he accidentally or
maybe intentionally undermined the
argument for gun control there because
we said at the time when there when they
banned bump stocks after that mass
shooting in Las Vegas I said this bump
stock ban isn't gonna do anything it's
not gonna stop any mass shootings it's
completely pointless virtue signaling
looks like I was right the bump stock
ban didn't stop this mass shooting it
didn't stop either of the mass shootings
this weekend it achieved nothing other
than to limit people's second Amendment
rights to protect themselves the other
thing to keep in mind here mass
shootings are not really on the rise at
least according to the most recent data
that we have so New York magazine which
is not a conservative publication
published a long piece on this in 2014
the number of mass shooting incidents
that involve four or more fatalities is
not really up since 1976 since they've
been keeping track of this number of
people killed and the number of
incidents has not really increased since
1976 it feels like it has but it hasn't
now what is different here is the media
coverage so people are covering this and
we all have an instant access to media
everywhere but what's up is not the
incidents themselves it's the media
coverage this is not a lot of comfort to
victims or families or people who see
these images on their TV screens but
those are the data those are the facts
and another factor which is now
unpopular is that mass shootings are
just one tiny aspect of our national
misery epidemic it's just one tiny
aspect of our national problem neil
degrasse tyson that a leftist scientist
clock that is broken is Right twice a
day he tweeted this out over the weekend
and he's getting a lot of flack for it
he tweeted quote in the past 48 hours in
the u.s. a horrific Lee lost 34 people
to mass shootings on average across any
48 hours we also lose 500 people to
medical errors 300 people to the flu 250
people to suicide 200 to car accidents
40 to homicide
via handgun often our emotions respond
more to spectacle than to data 290
people killed in just the last 48 hours
from handgun from homicides and from
suicides it's almost 10 times as many
people as were killed in those mass
shootings occur every two days that's
again that's no consolation when you see
these awful images on TV but those are
the facts almost 10 times as many people
killed every two days as were killed in
those mass shootings just in Chicago
this weekend seven people were killed 59
people were wounded from gun violence
just in Chicago that's one American city
just this weekend not a mass shooting
just the way it was and yet the whole
purpose of this hysteria this
sensationalism this vitriolic
exploitation of dead bodies on the left
is to get you to stop thinking they
don't want you to think they don't want
you to look at data they want you to be
so riled up by emotion that you do
whatever they say you saw these cynical
political hacks on television all
weekend they want you to stop
acknowledging reality on MSNBC they had
this this professor from Princeton Eddie
Glaude who told people that they
actually had to stop using the phrase
illegal immigrant because it contributes
to mass shootings but it's also
important for us to understand the kind
of continuity the line the connection
what does it mean to have a discourse in
which people are dehumanized where you
use a phrase like illegal immigrant
where the phrase itself places that
person outside of a certain kind of
sense of empathy and decency what
happens authorizing other right what
happens when we use language like
infestation children you use this
governor children this carrying perhaps
disease across the border what happens
you set the stage for people who are
even more on the extreme to act
violently we are in a cold civil wars we
are in a cold Civil War and there are
some people who bear the burden of it
Chuck listen to how perverse that is
listen
false everything he said is he said if
you tell the truth you are responsible
for mass murder right if he if you use
the phrase illegal immigrant it's not
even the best phrase the correct phrase
is illegal alien illegal foreign
national in our country if you use that
phrase if you point out that they carry
disease and crime over here you are
responsible for mass murder then he
turns the rhetoric up even higher he
says there were in a cold Civil War we
mean a cold war where you're talking
about a mass shooting so obviously
that's not cold that's hot and over the
weekend you had a radical eco fascist
and you had a radical leftist each
commit a mass shooting so it doesn't
seem like a cold civil war dole what we
saying is you have blood on your hands
if you tell the truth this guy goes on
television and encourages everyone to
lie allow your emotions to run away with
you and lie lest you calm down look at
the facts coolly and tell the truth the
time is now we can't wait don't think
absolutely despicable emotional
exploitation from the left
what should we actually do we should
grieve we should comfort one another we
should accept with resignation but
nonetheless acceptance that we live in a
fallen world even if these mass shooting
incidents are not increasing which
they're not even if gun crime is
decreasing which over a thirty twenty
thirty year span it is even if all those
things are true we live in a fallen
world we will never eliminate murder
hatred bigotry violence we won't
eliminate any of that this is a broken
world and no utopian scheme promised us
by the left is going to do it and no
amount of emotional manipulation is
going to lead to that utopia to that
paradise actually those utopias tend to
be hell on earth
we should calm down we should accept
that tragic fact of life we should
comfort one another and then when we are
thinking clearly
once all the emotional exploitation is
gone we should address these issues in a
rational manner there is something to be
done you could rebuild some mental
asylums you could make it easier to
involuntarily
people those two things would would help
you could encourage a culture that fixes
broken families the vast majority of
these mass shooters come from fatherless
homes and broken homes you could do all
of that you should do all of that you
got to do it in a thinking manner and
not allow these sick cynical political
anglers to exploit your grief and a
national grief to their own benefit
before we go speaking of these cynical
anglers so I just want to show the
bright side of this we talked about
tragedy now let's talk about for us at
the National Democratic socialists of
America convention in Atlanta the DSA
promised to topple capitalism and they
were this close they were so close to
doing a weren't they except they
couldn't get past the announcements
because all of the crazed leftists were
arguing about pronouns and phony medical
conditions and fake grievances and it
just it was absolutely hilarious take a
listen if we want to defeat capitalism
we are going to need a party that will
organize working people to fight for the
demands that we want and to win
socialism thank you so much privileged
guys first of all James Jackson
Sacramento he him I just want to say can
we please keep the chatter to a minimum
I'm one of the people who's very very
prone to sensory overload there's a lot
of whispering and chatter going on it's
making it very difficult for me to focus
please can we just
I know it's we're all fresh and ready to
go but can we please just keep the
chatter to a minimum it's affecting my
ability to focus thank you
Thank You comrade okay is there a
speaker against name point of personal
privilege yes please do not use gendered
language took to address everyone you
know I think they're pretty close
they're on the way it took toppling
capitalism but it's gonna be a little
longer it's gonna take a little bit
longer you couldn't see by the way in
the video when the god the first guy
talks about sensory overload
everyone just raises their hands and
starts shaking them but they don't
they don't clap because that would be
sensory overload but I assume it the
it's not just the auditory sentence
right I assume also the visual sense
could be overloaded so that I think
would overload it too and then just the
righteous anger of that second guy could
we please stop using gendered pronouns
and then I wanted the auditory the
sensory overload guy to get back up and
say please stop yelling so it's too much
and they could just get into like a
screech off that's basically what we're
seeing in the 2020 Democratic
presidential debate anyway this is this
is just the broader version of that it's
just I would say you know the the young
people the university campuses that's
the crystal ball that's what our society
is going to look like in 20 years so you
are looking at a preview of the 2048
whatever the year is a Democratic
presidential primary debates and it's
gonna be a whole lot of fun and I had
somebody tells me capitalism is gonna
win
something tells me capitalism is gonna
survive before we go I just have to give
a quick little review of Quentin
Tarantino's latest movie Once Upon a
Time in Hollywood I went to see it last
night with J hay and Andrew Clavin and
Spencer Clavin and it was a lot of fun
it's a very fun movie it's almost three
hours long but it actually flies through
Tarantino is not a great filmmaker but
he's a really good one so you're never
bored all the way through the reason I
would encourage people to watch it I
don't know that the film has a lot of
meaning it's pretty entertaining at
least by the end but it if the film has
meaning I I think part of the meaning of
it is how Hollywood went so wrong and
how in the 1960s and 70s Hollywood
basically cracked up and went just
totally off the rails and it's a movie
about how it might have avoided that
fate how it actually might have saved
itself Tarantino likes to go back and
fix history so he goes back and you know
the Jews kill the Nazis and you know so
on and said the this black slaves rise
up and kill the white slave owners in
the south this is a movie about that too
but it's got a profoundly conservative
tone to the movie there's a conservative
subtext so I'd encourage you all to go
see it's pretty fun you only get your
money's worth for three hours of
Judis violence and Tarantino
entertainment so might be worth might be
worth checking it out at the very least
you'll you'll be able to lament along
with the filmmakers and all of us the
demise of our culture that's our show
come back tomorrow we'll have a lot more
to get to we just had to get to this big
story today but much more coming up so
tune in tomorrow I'm Michael Knowles
this is the Michael Noel's show see them
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
Rebecca dobkins director Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring our
senior producer is Jonathan hey
supervising producer
Mathis Glover technical producer Austin
Stephens editor Danny D'Amico our audio
mixer is Mike Cora Meena hair and makeup
by Jesuit alvera production assistant
Nick Sheehan the Michael Nolt show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 19
hey guys over on the Matt Walsh show
today of course we'll be discussing the
horrific shootings that happened over
the weekend but I what I want to do is
go beyond talking points go beyond the
partisan blame game and talk instead
about what factors are really
contributing to this epidemic especially
what new factors in our society might be
contributing to this I have a few ideas
that I think hopefully get to the heart
of the matter
or at least get close to the heart of
the matter and we'll talk about that
today over on the Matt Walsh show